are you single now
i mean
[Music]
always i think you need to live in a
place where you're perpetually single
i'm thinking even when you're with
someone i think you're you're single
always i'm really good at being alone
are you good at being alone so good at
being alone it's my favorite thing when
i've run like with a bunch of people i'm
like oh i love you guys but like i'm
truly myself when i'm just alone and i
think
my album was such a manifestation of
just like
pure alone time i'm an only child do you
have siblings
look at us
i think being an only child and you know
loving that alone time was kind of one
of the reasons that i got so into
songwriting it's because you know
songwriting is kind of like a friend for
you and so i think that's like a really
amazing part of creation and i think
that also comes from being alone and
also being bored sometimes too i think
boredom is like the
like
the uh what's the word catalyst for a
bunch of
everybody get to board them in this add
enrich social
inundation society how do you get to
boredom
oh it's very hard yeah um
i think i like forced myself to do it
now too i i definitely force myself to
um sometimes sit at the piano even if i
have like no ideas just to like fool
around and i think there's a really like
cool thing about doing something like
that do you ever like force your phone
off take like space from things what is
your process i need to i very much
restrict all of my social media because
i think it's a such a time suck and b
can make you like so sad and depressed
sometimes because people can be really
weird on there um but
yeah that's a big part of you know kind
of maintaining mental health in today's
age i do think because we're moving into
like meatless mondays and the
plant-based movement and mental health
is so prevalent like why are we not
fighting for like a once a week phone
shutdown we should
literally sunday no one's on their
phones no responding to texts no
instagram posts let's start it let's
start it i'm serious there is
there is a shift a church-like spiritual
shift when you disconnect and i think we
need to make it this like cool hip
collective amazing movement that will
literally change
people's lives and days because when you
unplug the metaphor is too apt and
perfect
[Music]
you make room for other stuff
it means that
oh did a dream come true she is
the best
[Music]